the destruction of the novakarkov
kardown will have profound and
far-reaching consequences for Ukraine
from the immediate crisis to the long
term the biggest emergency right now of
course is the flooding caused by one of
the country's largest reservoirs
draining away to the South dozens of
towns and Villages lying along the low
banks of the deep Bro River have flooded
or are expected to be flooded and around
40 000 already vulnerable people are
thought to be in danger this is a
satellite picture of Southeast Hassan
from just last month and now look you
can see how devastating the flooding has
been but the fact that this area is also
a conflict Zone makes it even more
dangerous yeah another concern which we
have is the mobilization of landmines
and unexploded Ordnance so the snipero
Riverbanks have essentially been the
front line for months and we know that
mines will have been in place by Russian
forces potentially Ukrainian forces and
flood waters have the ability to strip
away soil and sand and
move landmines which are underneath
but the emptying of the reservoir is
causing problems beyond the flooding
Ukraine's President Vladimir zelensky
has warned that hundreds of thousands of
people in the region have been left
without proper access to drinking water
and agriculture officials have said that
tens of thousands of Acres a fertile
Farmland that once relied on the
reservoir for irrigation are now at risk
of becoming deserts in the next year
this would have a massive impact on
Global Food Systems Ukraine for example
supplies 35 of the world's sunflower oil
and in addition to all of this there are
now real concerns about long-term damage
to the Region's wildlife and nature
Reserves
as a result of the destruction of the
Kahoka hydroelectric power station at
least 150 tons of machine oil have
leaked into the river with the risks of
an additional 300 tons seeping out
this video shows a large number of dead
fish on the banks of the reservoir as
the water levels drop just at the end of
spawning season
it is too early in this unfolding story
to understand the full extent of the
disaster but it's now clear that
whatever happens Ukraine will be
counting the cost of this for many years
to come